what what do you like okay i found it so
what dr
seuss got beef with asians it's like it
seems like it's excellent
tell me those [ __ ] fires guys right
now okay so uh
dr seuss enterprises did not so two of
his
six books have been pulled i think he
had more than six
oh he had a [ __ ] ton yeah i guess again
the two
the six in question two of them have
been pulled yeah the first one is the
[ __ ] and the stink
oh that's the brandon shop show yeah
in five four three
two one hello everybody welcome to
another drunken episode of the genius
brain podcast
i have a little bit too much pinot no
tanner's them tanner's is feeling nice
oh those tanners dude they're [ __ ]
great
tanner's also known as tannins
and old tenons what hints am i getting
here this wine smells and taste
whisk it around a little bit oh my god
aerate it aerate it aerate it
mm-hmm ice ice okay hold on do that
thing where you start like slurping and
that's
like jello like you're trying to suck
jello through your teeth
oh singed hairs of a yetis [ __ ] oh
yes oh yeah are you getting that two pad
and a little shame i like it oh wow oh
i'm getting a semen in mine
oh david came in here compliments to me
david just cooked us a 17-course meal he
did it was great
literally all the leftovers in my fridge
because i made so i made this goal this
year that i don't
buy new groceries until i empty my
fridge wow i don't like that food
yeah it's been kind of rough because
it's like eating the same [ __ ] over and
over and it's just so when you guys i
was like i'm gonna [ __ ] feed you guys
all this [ __ ] and i was like it was so
good though it was delicious
the breakfast burrito was [ __ ] bomb
yep crispy [ __ ] bacon was nice
uh uh empanadas yeah you're homie made
beautiful and then i don't know how to
say what you said
yeah how do you [ __ ] correct them
they are also called girls
disrespect yoza's dumplings you know
yeah all of a sudden yes yes
okay i wanted the whole group of asians
in the house yeah you mean mariel
to he was like what are these called
gyozas and i wanted to be whatever you
identify as a mexican how dare you
yeah you were trying to get him to call
me the white devil huh
call him
judging our food i was like over here
bro what does
mean bro that's an old slope that's a
metal gear solid baby what you know
about that
that's some old-timey [ __ ] [ __ ] uh
the other day
what's it called [ __ ] everybody hit
me up just because i had that new puppy
right and i think because i post the
puppy every now and then every time
there's dog news
people want to let me know about crazy
[ __ ] that's happening with dogs and it's
also because you saved your dog remember
when that lady
stole your dog in sacramento i think
that's another one thing too
that's what it is so you're pr you're a
stand-up comedian
he's a part-time fighter absolutely not
part-time part-time beat up a man who
doesn't know how to fight once
stand-up comedian right podcasting i
actually assaulted that night
and i feel really bad influencer and
he's also
an animal rights activist yeah bang not
really i'd be eating those [ __ ]
like crazy they're
like but you'd be saving them though too
you know i mean you got a dick and a
[ __ ] i'm eating it you know
not sexually just i'm actually eating it
yeah like
yeah yeah yeah cannibalism style yeah
[ __ ] you're about the lady gaga [ __ ]
yeah bro we did that on jk news and
you know the good thing about jk news is
when i go on it like i learn about stuff
that i would never know about
same thing what were you saying no no
where was i my father my favorite part
of that whole thing was i got
so i got a headline i don't even follow
any news apps on my thing
i just got an alert i don't even know
what app it was i don't know how it got
on my phone
but it said lady gaga's uh dog walker
has been shot
and her two dogs have been abducted
right that was the first one i got then
like two days later
it was like hey lady dog lady gaga's
dogs have been returned safely
but no news about the guy who got sh i
was like is the guy yeah
he was fine he got shot four times in
the chest in the chest
in the chest bro i don't know how he
survived but according to tiff he lived
yeah according to tiff from jk news he
won oh he's definitely won he won
he won the battle that guy he
there's only one way you can survive
that many bullet shots is if you wrap it
up he's got to have some rhymes in his
giants dude exactly got shot four
[ __ ] times in the dogs that's a setup
dude that's not real if you have rhymes
swirling around in your chest you're
gonna be fine that's like teflon baby
we got rhymes swirling around in there
baby
got some dr seuss [ __ ] going on in there
dude
what yeah what happened with dr seuss yo
all these books are getting canceled
why guess what my [ __ ] jackass self i
was like oh you don't cancel these books
i'm buying all of them yeah they're all
sold out
everybody hopped on it because now
they're gonna keep it as a collector
maybe it was like a marketing move from
his
is he alive who is dr seuss dr seuss is
nuts well dr seuss and also what
happened chelsea was sick no they're the
same guy well he's people don't know
that
he is a well he's an artist first right
so he did like children's books
there's actually a an art gallery out in
new york
that sells his private collections so he
suffered from insomnia and so he was
like think of these crazy [ __ ] weird
ideas if you really
like think at it right look at the the
characters in his books they're [ __ ]
odd and obscure they're weird they're
like all psychedelic [ __ ] yeah so he was
like but it's cool though
it looks dope so his personal art is
just like the dr seuss books but they're
super [ __ ] dark
and they actually have like some of the
original pieces or
very like an x amount of copies of them
they sell out in new york at this one
gallery and they're pretty [ __ ] dope
man really trippy [ __ ] yeah yeah
so what's this way because i just saw a
headline and said he's racist and i was
like wait what happened
i mean there's like honestly it's like
six or seven books i don't think i
personally read
because if they got rid of the cat in
the hat oh we was gonna throw some
elbows dude
but i did see something that they said
that the cat in the hat was
like it was racist but my visceral
reaction was like [ __ ] off and i just
i closed it i was like [ __ ] this bro
what the [ __ ] are you kidding me dr
seuss bro the lorax is dope
yeah the lorax dude i speak for the
trees in my pocket
barbara what's in my barbarouts yeah
come on son doctors
i speak for the trees he was a rapper
shoot that guy in the chest he'll
[ __ ] survive anyway bazooka bro he's
full of rhymes
you can't you cannot cancel the cat in
the hatch i'm trying to assume
here's the crazy thing i'm trying to
find news from a published source
that's all blog and they're like you
know what nah you gotta pay
fifteen dollars uh yeah yeah of course
doctor [ __ ] time and washington post
yeah washington post they won't even let
you know what it's a lot of people dude
they said nine books what's
what's the issue i guess racist images
are like racist drawings what
oh you know what it is it's all
blackface i was like they're not even
humans it's all jewish propaganda films
i mean the hat's actually a white cat
playing as a black cat i think that's an
issue
the cat's quizzer i don't even know half
these books that's that's surprising how
old so
everyone's getting mad at this one how
old do you have to be
to be a japanese that's what it says
that's [ __ ] hilarious that's one of
the lines
the cat's quizzer the cat that has said
that
yep there's a hat with a caption
how old do you have to be to be a
japanese
but what was the degree of the slant of
the eye because that really depends
you know it was actually 90 degrees we
got to contact that teacher she'll be
the expert on
this yes that's not [ __ ] racist
that's what she says so born theodose
seuss geisel in the u.s state of
massachusetts in 1904 yeah that
[ __ ] did
1904 yeah dr seuss became one of the
world's best loved children's book
authors his works have been translated
into dozens of languages and sold
millions of copies in more than 100
countries dr seuss died in 1991 while he
lived a long time wow what the [ __ ] he
did
according to dr seuss enterprises his
works earned an estimated 33 million
before taxes in 2020
up from 9.5 million five years ago
so let's see the company said the
decision to halt sales of six of those
works came after months of discussions
and a review of dr
seuss's titles by a panel of experts
ceasing sales of these books is only
part of our commitment
to broaden our play or our plan to
ensure dr seuss enterprises catalog
represents and supports all communities
what what do you like about okay i found
it so dr seuss
got beef with asians it's like it seems
like it's exciting tell me those [ __ ]
firearms
right now okay so
dr seuss enterprises did not so two of
his
six books have been pulled i think he
had more than six though he had a [ __ ]
ton yeah it's done
i guess again the two the six in
question two of them have been pulled
yeah the first one is the [ __ ] and the
stink
oh that's the burning shop show yeah
uh dr seuss enterprises did not specify
which illustrations were offensive but
four of the titles contained cartoon
depictions of asian people
while three contain stereotypical
portrayals of the inuit
if i ran a zoo features a young boy
imagining a hunting expedition
to the fictional land of zoba matant
where locals in quotes wear their eyes
at a slant
end quote other pages show also the
african island of yurka featuring squat
african tribesmen
with large hoops through their noses and
to think
that i saw it on mulberry street has its
young protagonists imagining an
increasingly fanciful street parade that
includes
a [ __ ] who eats with sticks
a raja with rubies and a two fur clad
figures being pulled by
reindeer so most of it is just like
chinese guys
but you know i gotta say though when i
look at old pictures of asian people
they'd be looking like them cartoons man
like back in the day
yeah they use some goofy looking
[ __ ]
also bro this guy was born in 1904
yeah like if you if you take today's
world and you look at the past
through like that like our lens now it's
like yeah
everything was like racist back then i
guess
i guess they're kind of trying to keep
up to date with current climate which i
i guess i understand i think that's
necessary though
i don't think so because when i look at
those books if you
if you show like these asian people with
with you know slanted almond eyes
we do have that yeah it's just when you
use that as an as an insult is where
it's a problem yeah
you know what i mean if it's like oh
they have smaller eyes
listen we do we absolutely do what i
don't like is the cover-ups right it's
like
this is a part like unfortunately
whether you agree with it or not
and you like it or not it's part of our
history yeah right yeah
i mean like this is these are published
works
you know and it's not like we can go
back and just scrub it all out because
what's the point of that right well i
guess because they're still publishing
the books now right because they're not
it's not future it's not like the dead
sea scroll right the kids are still
[ __ ] buying these books
that's what they are that's what they
have to remake because that [ __ ] is mad
racist but they can't
but they could also we gotta cancel the
niv my guy
that [ __ ] is wow yeah dude they could
leave it up to the buyer though you know
like it's like hey if i don't want to
read this [ __ ] as a parent or whatever
then i won't
yeah but they're probably just covering
their ass for future stuff i think when
i see that it doesn't seem very i mean
as an asian person i don't find that
offensive like if it's just
you know characters with slant eyes i'm
like well there are asian people that
look like that
they're not saying it's all asian people
yeah they're right and i don't know man
it just seems like
it's it's they're really reaching bro
yeah you're trying to get dr seuss
like you're reaching what's next what
else they gonna scrub out from history
or
like kind of from like movies and stuff
are they gonna go back in
and i don't know you know what's kind of
crazy do you know the the backstory of
the ice cream song
[Music]
is it i heard it's racist it's like
creepy too like but that wasn't the ice
cream song dude i don't know what he did
what did i do
that was like you're like
what is the ice cream oh that's like the
i don't know how to do it i can hear it
in my head right now i can't do it do it
right now [ __ ] i swear to god after you
just roasted me
in front of like [ __ ] 100 000 people
you do it right now it goes it goes like
this
okay
i wasn't gonna do the same [ __ ] you did
it goes
ice cream oh there's a there's a youtube
compilation i can hear ice cream truck
songs
let's figure it out there's only one
no that's not an ice cream song that's a
pokemon song [ __ ]
that's a gameboy pokemon this is what
the youtube telling me no no no
go to the one this
this is exactly no you're right this is
from the pokemon game
that's what it sounds like right here
hold on
it was a song called turkey in the straw
all right thanks you [ __ ]
play the song like that
that's no that's a weird version of that
that's not it dude you know what that
sounds like don't get mad at me
all right [ __ ] man
i did uh ice cream and song racist
version
it's the [ __ ] song bro i can hear it
it is i know i know what i'm talking
about it's like when i want to draw
something i have i have no artistic
skills i can see it but i can't
stick figures when i know i need you to
try it one more time for us please
how's it going i don't know this is for
a million dollars
my parents didn't let me go to ice cream
trucks when i was a kid there's a lot of
this going on ding ding ding that's the
interesting
instrument is thinking
[Music]
no no that's a lot of songs you pulled
up sound racist as [ __ ]
whenever it's like hard but the hair
right there yeah that's that dude's
dropping n bombs
hold on we're going to find it right
where's the normal
[ __ ] oh
that's it
yeah because they they use that melody
for everything yeah
that song original title is edward won a
watermelon
wow bro it's crazy racist dude that's
wild bro let's let's cancel that [ __ ]
bro
people just people just want to just say
whatever they want back in the day it
was fine they could say whatever the
[ __ ] they want
you can name a song whatever you think
this podcast is brought to you by
cbd farmhouse my friends if you haven't
heard me talk about
this stuff right here well then you
don't know me at all and this is an easy
easy ad placement for me to do because i
use this stuff on the daily whether it's
their sleepytime gummies
their tinctures their topical ointments
whatever you name it
but right now the product that i love
the most is the sleepytime gummies
because i have been having a lot of
trouble
sleeping lately specifically because of
work and my my time schedule has been
all messed up
these things knock me out and the best
part about it is it helps me wake up
without feeling groggy
i love it if you're sore you guys can
use their freezing roll-on you could use
their topical creams
whatever you want cbd farmhouse has
it and guess what for my listeners out
there
if you guys want to try their products
and you are
sworn in and you guys are convinced
because i use it all the time
guess what you can get 15 off by using
my code brain on their website
cbdfarmhouse.com
enter codebrain to get 15 off once again
the cbdfarmhouse.com
enter codebrain to get 15 off i love
this stuff and i know for a fact you
will too whether you have anxiety muscle
aches
pains whatever you need to chill out cbd
farmhouse has it for you
love you [ __ ] so it goes you
i'm gonna say replace the word with
ninja okay okay you
ninja quit throwing them bones and come
down and get your ice cream
quit throwing them bones and then black
men incredulously
ice cream and brown this is the person
that's singing
yes ice cream colored men's ice cream
watermelon
dude so ninja level watermelon
ninja level watermelon for here they're
made with a half pound of
c-o-l i don't know that's some old
people [ __ ] coal there's nothing like a
watermelon for a hungry
[ __ ] oh wow this song is
terrible hey but you canceled dr seuss
though huh
brown simply used the well-known melody
of the early 19th century song turkey in
the straw
which dates to the even older and
traditional british song the old rose
tree
[ __ ] these titles the tune was brought
to america's colonies by scot irish
immigrants who settled along the
appalachian trail
and added lyrics that mirrored their new
lifestyle yikes
what in the [ __ ] dude that's really bad
i still can't do it dude he was giving
like new lyrics in the 1820s
where instead of it being titled that it
was titled zip [ __ ]
bro zip code this is crazy this is what
is the zip
what does that mean this is so funny
it's like when you when you kind of look
up history like this
and then you go to now people like just
get over it oh my god brother
yeah there's a lot there's a lot for
sure
bro if you're making songs about like
another race like that bro that's that's
rough
dude there was something i saw that i
wanted to fact check just to see if this
person was just being uh like a little
[ __ ] yeah
and you know everybody's on their sjw
[ __ ] but they were bringing up this
factoid where back in the day
um it wasn't a very widespread practice
but there was a
he was either a physician a doctor or
something like that
but he per but he loved having leather
goods made out of like black slave skin
yo what like shoes
wallets he it wasn't and it was i looked
it up on history.com where they fact
checked everything right
they said well if you did hear about
this it's actually true but it wasn't
very widespread
it was like specifically this one guy
that would talk about how much he liked
it he goes
i like it in my my shoes my wallets and
he would it would be made out of black
people's skin because he thought it
looked beautiful and he would skin them
wow that is [ __ ] vile bro
dude i'm telling this country has some
[ __ ] up [ __ ] it's got a dark dark past
that's why when they were tripping on
like remember when uh jango came out
they were tripping on quentin tarantino
like
why this white guy made this movie or
whatever and he was like
they were he was kind of saying like bro
like this is just
like a depiction he was like my movie it
was probably worse than what my movie is
yeah you know i mean which is true like
they had dudes skinning [ __ ]
and wearing them with shoes
like crazy like the history of america's
history is dark
but like if you don't if you watch that
[ __ ] and you don't feel like
angry to a certain degree i think
there's something wrong with you
like you know i mean like when you watch
like certain parts of like you know it's
a movie but it's still like
it's [ __ ] up like this is great like
to really think like oh yeah that's how
our country was
how did you feel when jeremy lin was
called coronavirus i was like get over
it chick in the stink
the chick had the sting oh you know
new podcast name i think we should do
that i think
we should do that i'll be the stink and
you'll be the champion
that's perfect no more no more uh big
mad anymore yeah
the [ __ ] and the stink i'm gonna come
up with the name for alex like what's up
he's saladorian
yeah dude but that song is it's crazy
and i had no idea
maybe that's crazy and we still need pat
to sing it right now
i think it is lyrics
oh
i bet you watched it though that [ __ ]
netflix documentary about that hotel in
l.a oh you're talking about the hotel
cecil
cecil people's yeah what the [ __ ] is
that about it i couldn't tell you this
the problem with certain documentaries
is that they should just be
one episode yeah the sisa hotel was four
episodes
and three episodes too long you didn't
like the [ __ ] three different
documentaries about r kelly raping
that could have been done in two
episodes
but like even that one was better done
than this one
the hotel cecil it was because they
would give you these facts
not like facts they would insinuate
certain things that happen
in this mysterious case that were so
later debunked in the last episode
that it was like oh just say that from
the beginning because the reason why
you're watching this is because of the
speculation
because this woman was found in the
water tank of the hotel
do you know the story uh not that part i
didn't get that
so some canadian chick came to
eleven a woman yeah you can't say chick
come on people get mad at you for
sanchez i think so everything's
sensitive but i heard like
i don't mean dudes female is very
derogatory
is it yeah yeah i'll give me some
females later bro
what do you say i guess like girls feel
like you're kind of talking like they're
an animal
like an animal yeah i see female more
that like i understand that being more
than a chick like saying chick when i
say a chick i don't mean anything like
that but whatever
uh so this girl from canada she's like
18
she came to vacation in los angeles you
need to get away
and then she stayed at this cecil hotel
which is like the craziest history
richard ramirez the night stalker
would go and stay at this hotel like it
was a lot of it's right in the middle of
skid row
a lot of homeless people would would
live there because it's like really low
income and it's like
three bucks a night or whatever it was
supposed to be like this um
really well done hotel that's cheap
that's
cheap for people to stay and it had like
it's glory and hay days
but then there was the great depression
that happened then it just [ __ ] it all
up
and then you know they i'm so glad they
explained what skid row is they're
getting a whole dock on skid paper
absolutely barely touched upon it right
it's more fascinating
than than this documentary oh 100 let me
tell you something
when somebody breaks open a hydrant in
front of me and then [ __ ] bidets his
[ __ ] with
underwater that's that right there was
i i couldn't even laugh i was just
shocked because loki you're like
[ __ ] genius it's like it's like the
walking dead in real life yeah you drive
through there dude it's crazy
to top that off he then had an open
suitcase and collected the water and the
suitcase zipped it up and started
walking away
as water was spilling out the suitcase
no no you're lying no leaks i refuse to
believe
that there was leaks out of this oh you
mean the fabric suitcase
the pine green fabric suitcase it was a
jansport backpack
i can't even let this is so sad but at
the bottom so
that felt so good washing my ass i'm
gonna collect more to wash my ass later
i'm gonna save some of this i need some
more gets home he's like [ __ ] where are
the water cooler
this one is good almost like around the
corner
damn that's foul dude and then she she
was
missing for a while nobody could find
where she was and then she ended up
being in the water tank uh on the top of
the building
for like weeks right for weeks and then
some
some of the people that were staying
there the water was brown
drinking it drinking it shower brushing
their teeth in it they're like it was a
little funky i don't know
what the [ __ ] got it the human it was
human blood
yeah so what happened so
she this this girl i think she suffered
from bipolar
oh she was she was bipolar and then she
was uh
she was undertaking her medication
undertaking is that the word i don't
know
she was uh under consuming her
medication that she needed and she was
having a manic episode
so that video of her in the in the hotel
lobby
and she's like looking around and she's
kind of like it looks like someone's
chasing her
they're like like who's chasing her in
the documentary they frame it as someone
is there
oh we cause you know what it is too they
also reference these youtube salutes
these people that like go on youtube and
they investigate oh yeah these [ __ ]
experts
because they're so [ __ ] qualified to
do
investigations right they're saying like
oh there's a shoe
in the shot i don't know where the i
don't know what's happening like
somebody's there the hotel uh the
elevator doors weren't closing so that
means someone was holding her there
it looks like she's talking to somebody
right was it one of the the
theory like wasn't the video edited
wasn't that one of the big pieces
and they kept saying that in in the
documentary like oh the video was edited
yada yada but it wasn't
so all the points of speculation in the
end or had
very reasonable explanations like all
these youtube sleuths kept like
speculating
and like they just go down this rabbit
hole and what the problem is is that
they're looking it
from a very small lens and they're only
getting the information that the
that the cops release to them so they
don't get the whole picture so they're
trying to like oh my god what's
happening
and they're adding more [ __ ] to the
[ __ ] pile of misinformation
as always and what happened was was that
she was having a manic episode
she was looking around and she was
having delusions apparently
and and it seemed like somebody was
chasing her because that's what she was
seeing
she made her way all the way to the top
looked at the water tank
and was reaching for it something and
then she fell in and
she probably couldn't get around to
death she drowned to death and that's
what happened right
but there's all these like certain
things that they talked about where
oh her clothes were gone her clothes
were off
at the bottom she was naked in the water
tank so that must mean
foul play right but really what happens
they have
scientific explanations they're saying
that when you get into a water tank like
that it's probably
you're really cold and you feel
hypothermia so
when people feel that way they start
stripping their clothes off to kind of
get warm whatever
right and that's what happened and then
all these like
theories that turned out to be like just
there was there was no reason like this
story should have just been
this it was a very unfortunate story
about this girl who had a mental health
episode
she passed away she saw accidentally
brown water and they were like
looks good to me yeah and this drank
drink it also
this hotel will get crazy this hotel is
not stupid like you know what the part
that was cracking me up was when they
were interviewing people who used to
stay at that hotel yeah and there's this
one dude
this was just just just [ __ ] hookers
there the whole time he was like oh that
play will pop it back in the day
i'm like you did not need to interview
this man right here
or put him in the documentary like there
was no he was he was probably the best
part of the documentary he's like i'm
over here just walking up to these
ladies of the night and i'm having my
fun
and i'm like what do you have to do with
anything
like just go away he's like who the [ __ ]
is that
he's like the [ __ ] you talking about
he's like i was slaying [ __ ] up in this
place if you talking about murders i was
slaying [ __ ]
bro the crazy story though is that
richard ramirez was
living there when he was murdering
people and they would have stories of
him
walking all the way up to the 14th floor
where he stayed
just covered in his underwear and blood
and nobody said anything because that's
how crazy the hotel was like
the people that would go there were just
like
you didn't know who was standing next to
you isn't there like a satanic element
to it or something like that
kind like there's a lot of hurt like
that there was a well it's just like so
many people have died there
like all this crazy [ __ ] like the people
that it attracts
are just not very good people so what
they did was they try to rebrand the
hotel right
the very top of the hotel i guess
there's a lot in la where
they have to have lower income housing
for all the people that kind of live in
the area
and but the lower floors
they they could be renovated and that's
what they try to do so the
manager at the time was saying hey we
could create a new hotel with new
branding
within this cecil hotel so there's a
cess hotel and then there was a hotel
called
a stay at maine and it was like really
nice looked young it was kind of like a
hostel
and that's where this girl found this
truly cheap room
but they were saying that when you're in
this room when you're in these this
hotel
you don't know who you bump into all
types of crazy
scary people and that's what the whole
speculation was they and they kind of
mislead you in the documentary
they kind of like tell you like oh like
see foul play foul play foul play and
then they try
they blamed it on this one like punk
like no he was like a metal head or
something like that
and all these youtube salutes were
saying like yo
this [ __ ] he's like it's a death
metal he's talking about like murdering
people
and they're saying this guy killed elisa
lamb he's the one
they have no proof bro they've ruined
this [ __ ] guy's life
they're commenting crazy on all of his
[ __ ] like you killed lisa lamb you're a
murderer yeah
he like i forgot what the extent like he
was like suffering through depression he
was like i didn't kill this girl
and they're saying like you were at the
hotel the same time that she was there
and turns out
he was there a year before wow a
calendar year before
while she was in the hotel and they kind
of ruined this fool's [ __ ] career
saying that he murdered this chick
there's like a youtuber that does that
too i think his name is like like cream
star or something like that oh great but
like this guy's name like cream star or
some [ __ ] he has cream pies on the side
he's like this 50 year old dude that
does
uh youtube drama he just talks about
like kids drama what's a youtube drama
i don't [ __ ] know some useless [ __ ]
but he just he's 50.
he's like a 50 year old guy he might be
40 something or something like that but
he's like a grown ass man
a loser yeah but this guy literally
finds dirt about
any type of youtuber possibly tries to
ruin their [ __ ] career and he did it
to this one older man who's like a
streamer
and he said that he was like a pervert
or a rapist or some [ __ ]
this this older man who just likes
playing games
got his life ruined like people were
attacking him calling him a rapist or
whatever going on his twitch streams or
whatever
and this guy was just so fed up he
starts bawling he goes i'm
not i'm not a pedophile like who what
the [ __ ]
and so he had like very substantial
circumstances like
evidence and he just almost wrecks this
older man's life
over nothing and this guy still has a
youtube channel today and he makes
millions of views don't you get sued
over that and can't you like
defamation right it's false stuff that
old guy actually can sue him for
definition right he can't
i'm surprised he hasn't done it yet he's
probably just so like i don't even i
don't want to hear this [ __ ] guy's
name yeah
because dude that's so irresponsible
because you could make claims about
[ __ ] and it happens all the time where
you could just say you could say
whatever and now the age of the internet
it just becomes fact
it's weird if you hear this guy talk
like this guy cream star when he talks
into like a
a video i saw him pop up on twitter
because logan
paul said something about him and you
know that guy the h3h3 guy yeah yeah
he said something along the lines of um
he wishes death upon them or assumption
or something upon like their family or
whatever right what not right
and so this guy cream star is on uh
twitter saying like you know what
that's like so disrespectful like i
can't even believe somebody was i'm like
bro you're like 40. why the [ __ ] are you
talking like a 14 year old girl dude
yeah what else
wrong with you he's married he has kids
too i'm like what the [ __ ]
is wrong with this guy loser [ __ ]
that's how you made your money dude yeah
that's how he makes all awesome he's
balling dude all he does is find
teenager
like angst and drama and he just talks
about it he goes in today's news
like i saw one video i had i think it's
called cream star
what a [ __ ] loser this guy is yeah so
i was like i can't watch this stuff i
mean
yeah you know you know kudos to him to
fig making that money or whatever but
i guess that's like a dirty way to do it
very dirty just tear people down you
[ __ ] lame ass
he sounds like a [ __ ] little cuck
that's what he sounds like yeah
yeah dude like what imagine that's what
you started that's what you made your
[ __ ]
youtube channel on what's your life like
bro yeah dude you're investigating
he's married he has kids married has
kids i'm sorry his
cream star i was like his name is
keemstar i'm sorry
i don't know i don't know what that
means oh his actual name is daniel keem
oh yeah cream stuff i'm sorry dude i
didn't mean to say that [ __ ] but
i wasn't trying to make a joke you
should just call him yeah
yeah his channel is called drama alert
drama alert dude it's [ __ ] what's
happening
some people i just have to see their
face i want to see this [ __ ] bro
eam star this is probably how he you got
[ __ ]
he has like six million um six million
subscribers hey people like the
cheeseburger look at this
the title of his videos james charles
needs to be put in jail for this
oh yeah wait is this him the guy with
the makeup on that's him no that's no
that's that's true
who the [ __ ] is james doesn't know what
[ __ ] that is
what a loser right you [ __ ] idiot
dude you don't know who james trump that
was nick for a second
my lips ain't that big is this dude is
this four-year-old guy right here
and he's talking about like young
youtuber teen drama as living
low-key like good for him but also [ __ ]
nah what a lame bro
i mean good for you man you made that
money bro but literally but at least
come correct with the facts bro like
you almost ruined somebody's life man
yeah you're like slandering some poor
guy's name
drama alert i only found this out
because when i
i didn't know who he was right and on
twitter i wrote this comment
you know i'm just making jokes on
twitter i was like i could understand
what this guy's saying but why does this
[ __ ] fifty-year-old dude sound like
he's like a 14 year old girl yeah right
he's making a joke or whatever sure
and then a bunch of fans saying [ __ ]
this guy this guy's trash this is all
the stuff that he's done i'm like
who is this dude so i kind of wanted to
look into it and he has
he's a pretty sus ass character man like
he's he kind of has like this moral high
horse where he's like
i'm here to i'm just giving out the
[ __ ] news to people and i'm trying to
take down people who are bad i'm like
bro
you're like a thousand years old and all
you do is gossip about what little kids
do you're
a [ __ ] pedo dude yeah he's gonna have
some skeletons in the closet
for sure that's where we start and then
he's gonna do a video about me he's
gonna ruin my whole career
hey cream star i'm like i'm sorry
keemstar i'm so sorry uh creepstar's
good screenplay star
i don't know him personally all right i
only know the surface level facts from
what people have sent me yeah yeah but
that's not my favorite person
we could just talk [ __ ] and say whatever
bryce hall cheated on addison ray
leaked texts 75 000
ksi ban pewdiepie strikeout it's
literally any kind of like
teen youtuber that he just talks gospel
yeah i'm like all just negative
snitch ass [ __ ] yeah somebody needs
to [ __ ] ass up yeah somebody's gotta
[ __ ] this dude
he looks like binging with babish that's
what he looks like hey binging
[ __ ] with babish
[Music]
damn dude am i having a stroke i don't
know anybody's name hey he's hanging out
with me
there's definitely people who cook on
youtube that i watch because i love
watching youtube
cook videos right bending bending
so we're done with this podcast i just
literally [ __ ] made a [ __ ] uh a
[ __ ] pakistani movie right now bindi
with bobbish
indian food and it's going to hurt your
stomach
and i don't care but um this guy
there's a lot of like youtube cook
people i like their recipes they're
really good for like foundation cooking
but when they cook all their food looks
unappetizing to me man it looks like it
doesn't have soul
you know why because it takes so long
for them to make it
amazing especially when binging with
babies like there's some stuff that he
makes is really [ __ ] dope
but a lot of it is like oh this is cool
to kind of see the process of how
certain things are cooked from like it
makes me never
yeah because it looks so like oh my god
this poor guy goes through so much work
so when you have over here and you have
the glutamate state attached over here
to the proteins and i'm like
i'd rather kill myself loki that's awful
like there's another guy named joshua
wiseman who's really good too
oh i used that after you mentioned him
to me i saw his videos his food looked
good dude really good that bro
that dude's food looked [ __ ] good
yeah his videos are cool to watch too
yeah he's fat too so i'm like you know
what's up
that boy got cakes on him dude he had a
little nagita
is his channel just called joshua
weissman yeah he's dope he's really
funny too he's a funny dude he's really
funny i like him a lot
gilbert put me on game on him oh gilbert
would love him that [ __ ] fat
[ __ ] it's okay guys we could all calm
down
yeah and i'm also fat too if i could
call him that song
damn dude cream star man that's a good
name it's so weird
like i i don't understand oh how are
people so open
like how is it how has it become so uh
what's the word like just how are people
so comfortable snitching nowadays
i don't because people aren't getting
shot like i want people there
or their ass bro i went on twitter i
never go on twitter i went on twitter
like a couple weeks ago just like what's
going on here it's just literally
this guy said this that guy did that
he said this to her i was like he said
this to him
damn like why is every everyone it's
just a snitch fest
i'm just trying to enjoy a life man
that's why like i don't do like people
want me to do these rant videos all the
time right and i'm like
do i look like a snitch to you
[ __ ] it must be so exhausting
sometimes it's it
kills my spirit yeah snitching is shame
like it's shameful
yeah are you ashamed of being such a
snitch all the time
if you have like a a warrant like if
there's a reasonable thing to say like
edward
snowden level like hey this is some [ __ ]
there's a problem here bang
okay yeah that's good he said this to
her he
was like bro what are you doing and also
too it's life
yeah it's also like whenever you see
someone that just only talks about other
people
red flag you got to raise a big red flag
because it's like you got to be at least
a little self doubt self deprecating you
gotta like talk some [ __ ] like you gotta
be a little honest about yourself too if
you're gonna be
shining the light on everybody else you
know like i don't like you know what
a lot of people go and i think there's
like a psychology behind this too don't
ask me
i don't read
and this is not just a young person
thing um
people tend to gravitate uh or develop
friendships
based on hating somebody else like
making a common enemy
so i had um a friend she's younger but i
had to take her side in a conversation
with her
because i she had a habit of developing
relationships by talking [ __ ] about
people but within the same circle so
word gets around
yeah right so i had to take her aside
i'm like hey yo cut that [ __ ] out
right and she was like what like i'm
just like we're just having conversation
no no what you're doing is
you want to be the fat person in the
group because you know this and this
about everybody else
and so you're creating these pseudo
bonds by developing hate towards a
specific individual
every time you develop a relationship is
based on hate oh what do we hate about
this person oh this [ __ ] is [ __ ]
whack and then you go to that same
person you were talking [ __ ] about
and talk [ __ ] about the other person
then you create this fake bond yeah so
you're
actually making drama only because you
think that you're developing
relationships with people
but everybody develops like these weird
like terrible bonds by creating a
singular enemy
yeah right and it's just the worst way
to do it you have because after that
enemy's gone
what do you have left nothing to talk
about yeah right literally nothing
it's that weird moral high ground right
it's like
everybody likes to actually to
it's like people want to punch up a lot
of the times too right yeah they try to
punt like like this [ __ ]
mega cream star guy green pie star guy
this guy
probably kill or he does kill
based on him just [ __ ] on people
that would never
give two [ __ ] about i mean he doesn't
care though like he only sees his
paycheck
right right and so mind you these people
who are going through their personal
stuff and by the way young people too i
never grew up with social media
so i don't know what it feels like to be
controlled by everybody else's opinions
yeah yeah we kind of grew up in an area
was like hey [ __ ] it move on like i'll
[ __ ] smash your teeth in
you know yeah see what'll happen but so
i don't know what it does to the mental
psyche right because
when you when he does this type of
[ __ ] right
and obviously we do it too when it's
like a huge headline that everybody's
talking about like oh let's have a
discussion on it
but this guy is literally snitching for
a [ __ ] living for a living
right and it's probably giving these
kids [ __ ] anxiety they're like oh
what's he gonna say about me is he gonna
cancel me because he has
he's gonna start like this whole like
fervor about how i'm a terrible person
and this guy lives like that yeah and
he's okay with it that's what scared me
about what was that documentary about uh
social media was like the social dilemma
social dilemma that's what freaked me
out is at one point it talks about how
social media basically hijacks young
people's minds
and and just in that sense like you said
makes you care about everyone else's
opinion
and like makes your anxiety of of like
where you fit in in the group
like because we all have that as social
animals like we're all like we want to
fit in but like you want to be an
individual
and that's kind of like a thing that we
all have to deal with or whatever but
like when everything's online and it's
like everyone thinks
you know you're ugly because this
picture with you this blah blah blah it
just kind of like amplifies
that whole that anxiety [ __ ] yeah
this podcast is brought to you by june b
matcha do you hate the jitters and crash
that coffee gives you well
say no more my friends because hundreds
of thousands of people are drinking
junebe matcha not only for the health
benefits but for the caffeine boost that
lasts without the crash of coffee you
can mix it
have it hot ice cold or try it with your
favorite juices and have
fun with it remember not all matcha is
created the same and junebe has the
highest quality matcha you can find
straight from a farm in japan
hand-picked and curated to get you the
best
quality there is no competition to get
10
off your first order of tins and packets
go to junebeshop.com
that's j-u-n-b-i shop.com and enter code
geniusbrain to get 10 off your first
order
that's j-u-n-b-i-shop.com
code geniusbrain it's so crazy how
people don't know that
like a lot of never done that flies
under the radar right
yeah hell yeah one of the shows though
is that some of these people that try to
cancel people
i feel like their heart's not in the
right place don't you think
like a good majority of them just kind
of like
oh what else can we find fault in
because whenever you're looking for
fault you're gonna find it
well they just want a pat on the back
yeah they want people to be like you did
a good
job for society which is awful exactly
yeah like when yeah
especially like like you're talking
about twitter right like oh she did this
he did that
it's people love retweeting that [ __ ]
they love like getting that echo chamber
and like it's like a hurrah like yeah
that guy
sucks he's a piece of [ __ ] there was
this there was this one young girl
and people coined her the boba liberal
it's like uh
what they call a lot of these young
asian kids that want to be angry
she got the the highlights in her hair
yeah yeah and she went after like uh
asian people who kind of speak in like
what she calls a hood talk which isn't
yet which is
what black people do and then there's
black people that are offended like well
what the [ __ ] every single black
person's ghetto is that what you're
saying like [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you're right so you know and here's
here's the problem with that right with
anybody who is
i don't know if liberal because i don't
i'm not into politics or anything like
that but if that's the term that you
guys want to use and that's the term
say super liberal yeah like these boba
liberals right
they want to have an opinion they want
to have an opinion about culture and
people
when you don't [ __ ] know anybody and
you haven't lived the life yet they even
speak you [ __ ] sperm
shut the [ __ ] up you were born yesterday
yeah right so you should
know that and keep your [ __ ] mouth
shut and they read these things from a
textbook i'm just assuming
exactly right but it's also like it's
taking it's taken out of context
completely yeah well that's what i'm
saying they don't know about these
cultures and people that they're
speaking
so adamantly about right like a matter
of fact i've seen her videos and i was
like this is
bad this is rough this is [ __ ] you
don't know
anything she goes well when uh peop when
asian people speak
in like like ghetto right they're
literally culturally appropriating black
culture i was like bro that's
the most offensive [ __ ] i've ever had in
my life yeah i was like i was like do
you even know what you're saying
and so china mcinerney had like an ig
live thing she wasn't she goes well i
learned this through somebody else
she wasn't even saying her own thoughts
she was regurgitating something that she
heard from somebody else which is a lot
of what happens
except in these all these situations
those echo chambers that's exactly what
it's like did you even have a
conversation with any of these people
that you're bashing or
people who are like this yeah so you're
talking about people for example there's
like asian people who grew up
in like who's gonna talk to stupid young
and say don't talk the way that you
speak
he grew up in long beach he's a long
beach crib and you'll be like
you're appropriating black culture
and it's not black culture that's just
hood culture yeah right
you know not that i'm defending it but
it's more like it's very offensive for
you to attach
[ __ ] ghettoness and goodness with
only black people bro you're not
you're not helping the culture out
you're actually being [ __ ] stupid you
[ __ ] people
you're being ignorant yeah being a
[ __ ] ignorant idiot i remember some
people in high school would be like why
are you talking black and i was like
what does that mean like what the [ __ ]
you're like dude
i've heard people say that yeah okay
they used to say that to jose all the
time the guy that what the [ __ ] black
guys at the
at the at the boxing things that do
sound as mexican as i've ever heard a
mexican person in my life
but he grew up in watts and he does like
if you talk to him more he does sound
like
like you know i mean he sounds black a
little bit so like he was like what the
[ __ ] like
and we we would tour with this guy who
was always like why are you talking like
that what you talking about he's like
[ __ ] i grew up in watts like what the
[ __ ] do you want me to like
i talk like yeah and like for example
too what are you gonna say to like
a korean person that lives out in london
and he has like a british accent
yeah hey quit appropriating british
culture right
exactly well what the [ __ ] you want from
me mate exactly like what the [ __ ] do
you want
dude also if that's how the guy you met
talks let him talk like that yeah you
think he's gonna listen to you if you're
like hey why do you talk like that you
shouldn't talk like that
you think you'd be like oh [ __ ] you're
right i'm so sorry and then
go about his day dude my buddy ed met a
korean dude
that grew up in india as a missionary so
this [ __ ] is literally coming
out good morning
you know that's exactly what he would
look like and say yeah he's like good
morning
today we are going to listen to your
scripture
your individual accent is very good i
grew up with uh an
indian uh travel agency next to my
parents store
yeah so i used to hear it all the time
yep and so
you know he didn't make that up right
100 percent indeed travel agents that is
legit
there was a kid named abhishek that was
their kid's name yeah
abhishek was a little ball and ass kid i
remember he
he used to have like this little tonka
trunk and i never had one and i was big
as [ __ ]
but your boy never had that [ __ ] so you
best believe i squeezed my ass
i was like this [ __ ] is mine i was like
[ __ ] you
yeah you think you're so cool don't you
i'm just going to take my truck that way
you [ __ ] son of a [ __ ]
i mean i think you should do the rest of
the podcast with that accent yeah
that's highly offensive it only works in
pockets and i only get away with it
because other indian people go that's
pretty [ __ ] good
why do you talk so indian how [ __ ]
dare you but usually when people ask you
[ __ ] like that or they're like why do
you talk all black like
well it's just a weird thing they're
quiet and it's so
uh it's just it's not that simple
nothing is ever black and white like
no it's not and it comes from people who
have never met other people
and let me tell you something the reason
why i also found her very irritating i'm
like
she's probably coming from a good place
let's see she is not coming from an
opera
she's somebody who wants to pat on her
back let me tell you how big of a
[ __ ] loser this girl was
right she anybody that writes their
[ __ ] school alma mater stanford on
there
just goes to show you want people to
think you're smart yeah right that's
your identity
yeah everything you care about stanford
right there good [ __ ] job dude who
cares
[ __ ] that dude [ __ ] her [ __ ] everybody
like her [ __ ] all her friends
dude but like you can't like give these
people credit like you can't let these
like i don't know i guess there's always
going to be people that are like yeah
she's right but at the same time it's
like i feel like most people
would hear her talk and think she's a
[ __ ] idiot right
yeah but you know but they but because
they see like oh is this the trend for
morality right now
oh i'm just going to agree with her yeah
and then people don't want to be on the
side of quote-unquote evil so because
she's in the
the the world of righteousness yeah
they're going to go towards that first
right so and it's so misguided too it's
like it's everything she says
too is like it's it's almost
she misses the mark so that's what i'm
saying i watched like
so bad i watched one video of her so i'm
you know i i want to support a youth
that is very vocal about [ __ ] like that
i'm like that's dope but she wasn't
saying anything smart
i was like do you really go to stanford
you [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah like what's wrong
with you
you're you're literally somebody who is
a textbook intellectual
like you read things and you think
that's how everything applies in life
you have you're you are in you're not
you're just in autopilot all the time
yeah that's how you are
yeah i [ __ ] hate that and it took a
dude uh [ __ ] china mac to sit down
and then
and then [ __ ] wreck this girl on ig
live and some of the comments were so
ridiculous too because i remember
reading it somebody wrote oh you think
you're so tough you're like a 30 year
old man bullying a 20 year old girl it's
like no no no
you opened your [ __ ] mouth so you can
[ __ ] get it too yeah
everybody loves claiming bullying yeah
are you a kid or are you a dog you can't
pick and choose
right you came into an adult space you
spoke to a [ __ ] adult like a [ __ ]
adult right so you only get [ __ ] man
or woman up like an adult that's all
that it is
it's so crazy because because now it's
starting to happen in like
the fitness community right so they're
just all ant
it's been recent too there's these
really smart guys his name is uh
dr spencer nadalski and he works with a
lot of obese patients
and all these um these anti-diet
people are saying that dieting is based
in white like
white supremacy what yeah how it's just
it's the buzzword to attach anything
that they don't want you to agree with
and it's just white supremacy you're
about to join the kkk real soon i'm
[ __ ] kidding by the way
eating salad you know like you would be
like they'll accept me
i'm like hey guys why power like
get out of here [ __ ] they're like hey
that's pretty good
that's pretty like they they're
preaching salads at kkk meetings and
[ __ ] bro
what the [ __ ] dude how are you attaching
white supremacy to [ __ ] dieting so
it's just like they're talking about
like
the standard of like the ideal body and
all that [ __ ] it's like it's like
based in whiteness and white supremacy
but they're pretty much saying that like
if you say something like they'll blink
if they type out the word obesity
they'll blank out the word
so it'll be like oh b and then star star
star
i could say like it's a curse it's a
curse word and
like this guy he works with
a lot of obese like uh patients like
that's what he does for a living like
he's a doctor
yeah and every his whole message is
probably one of the best messages
in the fitness industry right like he's
there to really help
you know and these people are coming
after them saying that like
you know you're they're saying he's a
bully
and they're they're making up lies about
this dude he said that you know like my
qualifications don't
and this one girl was saying like oh
like i'm actually i'm a psychologist
with obesity patients like
this is what i work with and he's like
okay cool like that's awesome he's oh i
didn't know you weren't you
you you're you're a doctor as well like
that's really dope and like
the way she explains how he talked to
her was like he was bullying me
he said my qualifications are stupid
that they don't like it's not real
and then he posts all of the uh
interactions and it's not like that at
all
of course she's making all this [ __ ] up
but people wanted to believe her didn't
they
dude so many people believed her and
people are like just saying and
what he's trying to do is just try to
help people that have this disease
to just learn how to do it the right way
right he's not saying like everybody
needs to diet and that's like the
fitness thing like some people get mad
at you for like promoting like
diet people get carried away with that
stuff remember the the the um
the gender reveal party thing right they
wrote this one [ __ ] on twitter wrote
this random [ __ ] which wasn't true they
go
a good job like bullying the lady for
doing the gender reveal part the reason
why she did it
is because she couldn't give birth to a
kid and every time she got pregnant it
died before they could find out the
gender
and the real story was she goes i like
pretty things that's why she did it yeah
cause she says i like to do i like
parties and cakes that was the only
reason in an actual interview she goes
i just like to celebrate things yeah and
then somebody wrote this whole thing
that said
it was because she couldn't uh give
birth or find out what the gender of the
kid was before it was born yeah and then
everybody had like 30k retweets and
likes it's like dude
twitter is not a place for [ __ ] facts
people but that's what happens but that
what's crazy is that there's like really
a battle of like
between truth and just complete [ __ ]
and somehow [ __ ]
seems to win sometimes and it doesn't
make any sense like with that with that
for example or with this guy with the
[ __ ] doctor
who because there's people that want to
believe it for some reason like they
don't want to
there's like people that i don't know if
it's like a a side effect of us just
being like kind of
spoiled in a sense that like things are
so good i think that we're just like
we're just like
looking for [ __ ] to be angry about you
know what i mean like i really don't get
it but it's like
once a fact is out there it's like how
could you dispute this yeah
so somebody wrote on the channel the
other day uh because i had to delete and
re-upload
uh one of the the podcasts because i
forgot to take out this clip of like
this racial attack it was from a
different video
and so i took it down and i redid it and
i forgot to bleep somebody's name out
and somebody wrote they're like david
had to redo the video because he was
saying a lot of it's racially
insensitive stuff
and then somebody got like 20 thumbs up
and then somebody were like what the
[ __ ] are you talking about he's like no
he did it because they said somebody's
aiming to bleep it out
and but 20 people thumbed it up they
they're right it's true they're just on
it yeah it's like yo man what the [ __ ]
is wrong with you why are you here then
why are you here yeah get the [ __ ] out
of
here
you know my name is david so comedy yeah
like don't what are you coming here for
yeah right [ __ ] my dude but also like
what you said like that
there's certain buzz words they try to
attach things to like white supremacy's
one of them
uh bullying is one i mean like there's
these certain things that
are the evil which it's like that's what
that's where it kind of gets religious
in a weird way
yeah where it's like it's you're
speaking heresy now it's like it's not
like
it's it's not we're that's how you're
not in facts world anymore it's just
like you are speaking the satan's tongue
and it's white supremacy it's bullying
it's all these fat shaming it's like
that's the new harrison you know what i
hate more than racist people
at least racist people are rooted in
ignorance right and they just
haven't known any better or they didn't
grow up around people who could teach
them better
right what annoys me more is [ __ ]
white apologists
right like they were because they are
the ultimate patney on the [ __ ] back
they're the worst let me educate you why
you are all evil like you guys are
terrible human beings and you need to
apologize
to every asian and black person mexican
it's like no bro you
don't all right just be like hey slavery
was [ __ ] up i understand why shit's
happening here
and i'll just educate myself on that
[ __ ] you know i didn't know about that
stuff my bad yeah that's all you gotta
go
but now these guys are walking around
just saying [ __ ] on their
fellow brethren white people or whatever
i don't know
yeah yeah dude race trainer dude
it's so misguided and we
there's a lot of comedy sorry there's a
lot of comedy where i would see
a lot of like white dudes being like i
know like do that
guilty white like you're just such a
[ __ ] dude
you know every time like race is brought
up to them they have to apologize it's
like you
don't have to do this just don't be a
dick
that's all you got to do just be cool
don't be an [ __ ] be a down ass fool
bro yeah
be aware of [ __ ] that can happen you
know what i mean be aware of the history
and whatnot but like
to be like oh you know it's like the
male feminist guys
it's the same thing it's like i'm sorry
for all men and what we've done to women
oh bro like bro you are a [ __ ]
you are a [ __ ] how do you look at
yourself in the mirror bro like what's
wrong with you and like i said i'm
always going to say this the reason why
i'm i get upset about it because it's
not rooted
in that person trying to do good yes
exactly exactly
are you trying to look good and it's
obvious it's very obvious
trying to get a leg up on everybody else
yeah it's super obvious i apologize for
the
for the entire race of men because we're
all animals like
imagine hearing that bro yeah [ __ ] yeah
it's like and we all know you're just
trying to have sex with girls and be a
weasel about it be honest
you know i mean like don't [ __ ] act
like what you're trying to say to this
girl is going to be like
oh i'm going to impress her so hard and
tell her like oh she
because essentially what you're doing is
you're you're telling people
what you think they want to hear which
is so insulting because it's
like so off most people don't want to
hear that [ __ ] imagine you're a girl and
you see this guy comes up to you
and they're talking he's like oh i
apologize on behalf of all men you'd be
like
okay like you're the [ __ ]
representative of all men get the [ __ ]
out of here dude i had a friend who was
telling me
that um when he was working like a
part-time job um
they all had like this like group
pow-wow and they were talking about
um like racial uh sensitivity stuff
that's been happening in this country
right
and there was a white dude that was in
the group and this [ __ ] in the
most useless information ever
right he goes i am what's the word for
oh a cis male what does cis male mean i
think it just means like a straight
white dude okay yeah i think it's what
it means i think it's just
gendered something that's what it means
yeah i have to look that up uh but he
he comes through and he just in the
beginning of the the powwow meeting he
goes
uh i just want to say that i am a male i
am a cis
male so my opinion doesn't matter
wow if your opinion didn't matter then
you should have just shut the [ __ ] up
why are you talking exactly get out of
here exactly
leave [ __ ] why did you say that
you know why because he's on a public
forum he's like hey guys i just want to
let you guys know that like i'm a really
cool guy and i want you to know how cool
i am
but thank you yeah sit down exactly he's
literally woke up he goes hey guys
i'm woke woke
that's kind of what bugs me about um
like if you're not
like if you're transgender you're coming
out and you put your pronouns out there
you want people to call you
her him totally understand hey
but if you're nick or you're david and
you've you're staying nick and david
you don't have to tell me or in your
profile that you're a he him
i'm not confused yeah at all i'm not
confused yeah hey you're just still
doing it yeah i'm gonna call you him
yeah because
it's not confusing to me at all in work
meetings and in emails and [ __ ] people
send like
hey meetings that it means at 8 00 a.m
like he her steven
yo hey [ __ ] i don't care yeah
when's the meeting exactly i don't give
a [ __ ] guess what i'm just going to call
you steven
yeah stephen hey you're not coming out
as trans you don't have to tell me where
your pronouns are
your name or if you haven't changed
anything i get it i know how it works
you're a guy or you're a girl
i've known you for 20 years yeah we're
cool yeah but that's another virtue
signaling thing where it's like you want
to seem cool
that's the worst dude like that's the
word right the phrase
virtue signaling that is the worst
that's like the grossest [ __ ] out it's
so gross because like you said
it's not rooted in good intentions and
not at all it's all about me me me but i
don't understand how you live like that
and like i like if you have any
integrity how do you social media baby
it really is yeah be like keanu reeves
bro
guys it's so dope bro old people seats
and [ __ ] for no reason
you don't say [ __ ] doesn't touch girl
like he takes pictures like this with
his hands like this yeah he never
touches
you notice i've noticed a lot of
pictures these with girls and like he
has his arms like this but
they never touch dude i'd be gripping
guys and girls all the time dude
he's like i guess he's like i don't know
if it's for legal reasons or what
because
somebody wrote this comment like way
back when it was like uh
it was like jk right and i'm i'm the
tallest longest one
so i had my shoulder it was like on tiff
or geo or one of the girls right it was
like this
and then my other arm was here they're
like why is david grabbing like tiff or
geo like that i was like and i wrote
back i said well you don't know where my
hands and
hands are next to bart's ass
ripping that [ __ ] nug back there dude
i got it
[ __ ] nug yeah those shits are idiots
bro virtue signaling is just an odd
thing man
and that's why like little moves like
this that instagram made i [ __ ] with it
dude yeah
getting rid of these [ __ ] like things
let's see how well you've unless
you're going to be the loser that goes
swipe you want to see how many likes i
got yeah
let me show you how cool people do that
oh yeah fang bros all the way baby
i love those guys what guys dude f-e-n-g
bros i love them it makes sense though
it does seem like a young man's game
though
or a young person's game like it like
because when you think about middle
school high school you are into your
image what you're insecure
you know you got a lot of [ __ ] going on
that's true but if you're like in your
30s
40s and you're doing [ __ ] kind of
dealing with this it's like you're a
[ __ ] lame-ass
weird like i don't get it i really think
it's the fact that you can't [ __ ] people
up
i really think that has something to do
with it i think that there's no like
like checking there's no checks and
balances anymore like they got rid of
bullying right so you can't even bully
[ __ ] anymore what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is that about that you
know what i mean like there's no there's
no sense of
uh confrontation at all every time you
write a youtube comment it should just
be [ __ ] habib i think this is same
location
you have to give like a 15-mile radius
of where you're at yeah yes
yeah there should be some sort yeah it's
something like that yeah like you know
exactly
if he's he finds you it's like at least
five minutes with you one ufc round
sometimes you read like certain comments
right and it's just like
the people that go on there and they
just have to say certain things you're
like man how [ __ ]
miserable are you bro not the genius
brain people not like jesus many people
are
encouraged conversation nah they're
great like it's never any of the genius
brain people but like
what whether you're like if you're
watching like a a mma show or something
like that
fight comment don't even get me [ __ ]
started god damn i [ __ ] hate him
like it's crazy or or like certain
people and like jk i'm like god damn bro
like people are [ __ ]
cutthroat yeah yeah some people are
different and they just go out there
just to like talk some [ __ ]
and then be like hey i did it man
everybody wants to have an opinion they
always want to be right even though your
opinion doesn't [ __ ] matter about you
doesn't it
it's just so stupid it's so weird bro
hey man be peaceful out there guys i
love you very much but that wraps up
this episode of the genius brain podcast
best fans ever
best fans ever you guys have just kept
me alive
i haven't sucked dick in two years
because you guys are sure let me tell
you something man your boy's about to
get rid of his teeth and just go
gum time you know when they call me on
the streets right they call me juicy
fruit baby
sweet tea juice
hey juicy fruit where's sweet teeth oh
i'm right here sugar
oh you know he just mixing me up in the
back
of the gum time man what you doing i'm
just brewing over here
yeah got him uh you can find nick dunn
at nick the ear what's your website
called
nicktheyear.com nicktheyear.com more
content blogs
videos everything is gonna be posted if
you guys are uh getting ready for that
summer bot it's coming up
make sure that you hit nick the air up
if you don't live around the area guess
what he does
online [ __ ] programming and also
check out my calorie calculator on my
website at nickthier.com to find out how
many calories you need to bulk or lose
weight
yep there it goes there it is you can
find patrick.t
dot riley at instagram and also
in your [ __ ] dreams
also in the bed with your wife
didn't give me shots all the girls out
there watching slide into my man's dms
wow look at this
guys i'm gonna get this man in trouble
we should probably tell the story before
we end about this guy almost blowing
your [ __ ] yeah
bro okay i meant i meant it no no you're
you're the worst friend ever i wasn't
trying to be
i just was thinking i was like it's
probably true because bro
people ladies love [ __ ] pat dawg he's
just doing it he just keeps doing it
right
it's true bro girls like patrick
they get googly eyes when they talk to
him i swear to god everybody knows this
i'm gay
and there you have it guys that wraps up
this episode of the genius brain podcast
pat is now gay i'm gay
bang he he hurt he he
and we love it either way whatever your
pronouns are
just let us know and i'll call you where
the [ __ ] you want to be called man yeah
yeah dog
but if you're staying steven just we got
it we got it man i've known you for 20
years stephen
stephen hey pat i know we grew up
together but i just want to let you know
i'm a he thanks for letting me know man
[ __ ] you see y'all next time
peace